Today we are playing king of the table.
The winner stays on, first to 11 points wins.
And there's a special rule if you win 3 points in a row
Lets go!
Two same colors start.
You start.
Okay, 0-0-0.
What happened there!?
Are you okay?
I could say that there's not enough room here!
Are you sure you don't want to come on this side?
I think I'm good thanks
I need to get my first point
That's how you do it!
Where did that come from?
Never play to Otto's backhand!
No!
My own spin!
That was my third in a row.
Special rule!
Only forehand because your backhand is so overpowered.
You saw that footwork?
Yeah!
When Otto has to do footwork he can do footwork
Well, that was my sixth in a row.
Should there be another special rule?
Yeah double special rule!
Right hand and only forehand
There's no chance I'm gonna win this point!
I had to go for it!
Nice!
Pardon!
Two times in a row
Don't give me there!
It feels like I've said that before
That's the biggest
mistake you can make.
This is unbelievable!
There's nothing you can do!
No!
Not even with the sorry point.
Yes!
Now that I deserve!
I deserve that one
What was that block?
Twiddle master
Match point!
Another match point
I also needed one.
You deserve that Emil!
Probably yeah!
So today the king of the table was the Sensei
Congratulations!
Thanks!
Anyway remember to subsribe here
and watch our previous videos there
Until next time!